hello and welcome back to hey B we can't
even say the name of our show right now
cuz YouTube is de monetizing us okay
hate us they hate women by the way who's
here right now TIFF is here Nikki's here
jess is here
Bo's is here and our wonderful beautiful
reduced our favourite coming back yeah
Gordon not being scared off the first
time it's fine you finally get to talk
about stuff like besides the same kind
of like this is my back so great oh I'm
so happy yeah anywhere yet where you
don't have to explain your whole
backstory
no but if I like the people I like look
them deep in the eyes and I'm like
invite me back started a group chat and
sent pictures of her eyes and then
forced us to come over and she stared at
us while we eat no she's amazing an
amazing cook also I am married to an
amazing cook we had the honor of eating
their food he crushed it that night yeah
I was surprised you pulled out the
shrimp and grits or whatever it was I
was like at the end of the night she's
like you guys want leftovers yeah an
addition additionally to the leftovers
and she was like oh well TIFF brought a
cake for dessert and she's like oh means
like let me check the ice cream maker I
was like homemade ice cream by the way
adorable I know I change it between
episodes and like I just Bose you're now
in my line of sight and you are adorable
I look like a poodle that's going to
drive a fancy proper poodle like a
poodle who lives in a band yeah
Georgette's on occasion that's always
been my ultimate van yeah I want to be a
poodle that lives like a mansion with a
nice like white family pillow and like a
diamond collar yes that's exactly
georgette
you're literally describing georgette
from Oliver and company Oh
absolutely once again back on the show a
hundred percent natural and today we're
talking about sex toys toys toys in case
you're not having sex sex you can stop
singing with toys it's not having any
sex I've only had sex two times in all
of 2019 Oh with the body I don't know
she I've had sex a lot of times with
toys my so my mom called me the other
day and she was like I see jess is doing
a giveaway for a sex toy yeah she said
she was she was just like wow did maybe
she got paid a lot yeah I just opened up
Instagram and there she was with a bunch
of colorful vibrant mom there is a
stigma with yeah sex toys and I want to
talk about that cuz why you know like
people should be able to pleasure
themselves even when they're not in
relationships with actual penises
yeah or vaginas those things are saving
me from sinning against the Lord by
sleeping with a whole bunch of random
people on random nights by myself doing
the dirty work
with my own self I'm not getting STDs
I'm not getting babies I'm not ruining
Marilyn and there are machine washable
right yes yeah they're dishwasher safe
oh my god imagine just pulling out the
dishwasher and there's a dildo but
you're just putting a plate around I'm a
single woman and I have my own apartment
now and if I want to put my vibrators in
the dishwasher that's okay go around the
table and let's maybe do like what what
do you think your experience with sex
toys is on a scale of one to ten well do
you have maybe not let me won't have a
number that I could point five for you
point five yeah so let's talk about like
do you have a sex toy currently have you
ever had a sexy you have one or you've
had one I have multiple yes for you
and then I don't use them alone oh okay
so I'm so [ __ ] noob at this cuz I
don't have any and I've never used a sex
toy I'll get to that really yeah so what
are multiple ones we have multiple
functions what is going on there I will
tell you okay so about five six years
ago I went to okay so my girlfriend she
actually had this like sex toy party you
know like Tupperware parties yeah we had
one of those and it was at my house cuz
I was like she she was hosting it but I
had a scam where they tell you like Mary
Kay yeah but the pyramid is just a bunch
of no this is like a candle party kind
of thing where you don't have to go and
be recruited to continue to sell it's
just you go and like you buy your [ __ ]
or whatever so anyway so I had this at
my place and oh no actually my very
first sex toy it was before this sex toy
party which was at the time I was
planning a wedding and not to Kacie and
I went to my own wedding no like I was
engaged before Kacie yeah yeah yeah so
then um my girlfriend and I we went to
this like bridal expo thing and one of
the gift bags that I got had a little
bullet vibrator that was the very first
thing I ever used that's a nice gift bag
yeah something nice something useful in
that gift bag right yeah no I love that
thing but it was kind of wack cuz it was
like a bullet well I mean it's whack now
that I know there's other options oh so
it was like a bullet but it was like
attached to like a cord and then like
the remote thing so it was like so you
stick it up there and then you press
about you give your partner at the
remote they play with it under the table
at dinner oh no you're attached like
I'll wait for my turn then but yeah so
that was pretty fun and then oh right so
then the sex toy party thing and then I
actually bought my very first like dildo
vibrator thing and it was called like
the Jackrabbit so really everyone had
that one like in case you don't know it
looks like a dildo and then at the
bottom base like there's like this
little like bunny rabbit that has like
ears and the ears like vibrate and then
the entire dildo thing has like like
little like beads in it or something and
they're kind of like it was wild yeah so
I wasn't a big fan of it but that was
like my first one so I was like oh is
this what it's supposed to be like I've
seen those before in the store the thing
with the little buddy bunny ears and I
was like I want to put that on my body
alright but but yeah I don't know like I
guess I wasn't really my thing
when we see one of those ones it looks
like it probably like feels really great
but then when you try it you're like oh
this is okay because there's this one
that's a little it's like a vibrator and
it's like a suction cup oh that's what I
yeah yeah oh yeah I know that's amazing
oh I heard it wasn't that great but when
I was not I just warned over three
hundred dollars yeah yeah it is insane
how I shouldn't say anything I did spend
a lot of money on one of my sex life
okay yeah we'll get to the what's the
other really girl I'm telling you I have
a long list we should just get back to
me later okay so for me I don't know
experience with sex toys I've been
curious but also I feel like because
I've been like serial monogamist I've
never gone longer than six weeks without
having sex even when I was single like
that was my maximum and so I didn't ever
want it to like ruin sex from not the
word ruin but like get me sensitize yeah
we're like sex doesn't feel as good
because my vibrator feels so good
because a lot of women are like yeah I
didn't want it to be like oh is taking
forever for me to come with my partner
but do you masturbate I do yeah yeah you
just [ __ ] full-on like that Anatomy
it oh no yes sometimes that's like the
easiest thing and it didn't take that
long Yeah right and I
like that's something my partner would
do like with his oh yeah and so it
didn't desensitize me like my own so I'm
not an internal orgasm or if that makes
sense it's all a journal for me ya know
like the only thing you have that people
out there think that because like in
porn like girls are coming all the time
like that that's what they should be
doing like this I too can tell it waiter
my food was great when it was bad for
sure thank you so much okay get to go
Wow
no you can't sleep over waiter you're
over here right artery gets obviously oh
Carlos is here to pick you but I did
have my mom okay so I got my friend like
gag gift one time that was a vibrator
pun intended
yes and my mom found the box and then
she would not believe me that it wasn't
for why you keep the bug no I threw it
away
oh she found it in the trash she's like
you have a toy now and I was like no it
was a gag gift for Tonya and then she's
like mmhmm yeah okay it's okay to have
toys she wouldn't let it go I think to
this day she still thinks your mom
thinks you're prude she's training her
to be a more adventurous your mom is
basically saying it's fine if you have
one you should have one because mom's
went through the the pain that we would
have gone through being raised in overly
religious families up until 30 and then
realizing like wait this isn't that bad
and they just want to let you know
they're like it's fine because I
remember my mom told me something
similar like when I had a breakup with a
boyfriend she was like well you know if
you guys tried toys it might like my mom
is like judging Jess on sex toys so like
I don't know I feel in balance yeah
because like there they were raised like
oh yeah don't talk about yeah kind of
like therapy like how the generation
above us so they were raised like no you
don't need to see a therapist you know
you're not crazy and now we're like hey
everyone should see therapy a therapist
yeah leg in the sixties if you're like
I'm going to therapy they're like oh
she's getting
yo ya gotta bottom nice so I'm
interested to hear more about your sex
toys because I have no experience I only
have two and they're both the same brand
womanizer yeah sponsor me I love you or
at least send me some free [ __ ] because
they're [ __ ] expensive oh [ __ ] you
guys were trying to avoid Cosmo you can
cuss away girl fantastic so I just got
the new one and it is insane what what
is different about it the only thing
that's different is it's a hundred and
twenty dollars more expensive okay but
it has different functions like more
settings more species I guess it hangs
like you know is it like a mountain bike
like you got one years now it starts off
like this alright hold on it starts off
like this we just met you know somewhere
here and then and then it goes up one
and then more and then more and then
more and then more until honestly you
don't even need that many setting you
seriously after I got the new one I was
like what the old one is if my fingers
are fine the old one was more than fine
I don't know why I bought this one but
I'm so happy I did so many different
shapes it's shaped like like this okay I
don't think it's suction either it's
blowing air yeah yeah I don't think
that's yeah it's not it's kind of like
it just creates you put it over like a
cup of water you can see it like blowing
air and they're like welcome video on
their website speed of your analogy with
the waiter that you're in the restaurant
but no I love mine and Robert has
learned to accept them um I am the type
of person who like wants it before I
fall asleep and if I'm bored in the
middle of the day or you know if I'm if
I have anxiety I need a man yeah exactly
like I do it throughout the day on a
daily basis unless you know I'm on my
period then I'm on the moon oh I like it
my period it's like actually it's like
wet or
so it's yeah near the tail end of my
period it's fine but at the beginning
when I ran pee and there's a rollin say
yeah so it's super helpful especially
since then I'm not like wearing Robert
out because so he my sex drive is like
here and his is like sorry I'm so sorry
damaging your equipment no no no get
closer today so talk about his sex drive
is here and my nope
mine is here and his is like here so
it's very rare for us to like get on the
same page yeah so you're talking about
like your partner controlling your sex
toy during dinner is he into that is
that something that you guys do together
yeah he's not really into like public
things like that but I've done it before
I'm into that me doing so what cuz okay
I've been trying to get Steve to have
sex with me in public
like not in front of everybody but like
no yeah wait to a spot and like we might
get caught
so axillary yeah it gives me that type
of high and he won't do it yeah but
maybe he'd be down for this type of
thing were you just like you had it we
don't even tell him about it just hand
him the remote at dinner he'll be it to
intrigue this is the hottest moment of
my entire not at a restaurant with
mountain with a metal chairs make sure
it's it is from experience famous
bleachers don't work either Jess I do
master experiences I've had sex toys I
think since I was 18 since you were
allowed to go and legally purchase them
how nice of you to like wait till the
legal oh yeah I don't think so anyways
yes so I have I've tried all kinds
nothing too crazy though I mean you know
like that the story if you walk into the
sex stores you'll see like the crazy
ones like there's a drill doh Oh drill
with a big dildo or the ones you put on
top of stationary bikes yeah yeah
the one that's attached to that workout
so yes the work yeah well you know that
you know the big ball that you like have
the medicine ball yeah
oh that would be kind of fun to like the
bouncy well yeah so I've never tried any
of those and I actually don't like
dildos
yeah just like vibrators and but the new
ones that have been coming out those
suction ones those [ __ ] suction ones
there's a ton of different brands
I've been sponsored by a certain brand
and I've used that one and I've also
given one to Tiffany to try I have
recently used it that kinds a little
weird you have to kind of figure out
like how to use it it's not quite as
like obvious like if you just got to get
it the right position and then maybe
turn it up all the way then you're like
whoa yeah yeah yeah over your clitoris
yeah like that yeah what the bright with
a vibrator it's like so it's just like
wow yeah you gotta put it anywhere and
it'll work but with these it's kind of
like you got to find the right position
for it but those are amazing I've gone
in 60 seconds or less
oh yeah I mean it works fast oh yeah
yeah like and the desensitized
desensitization thing that you were
talking about is totally true because
now I've tried masturbating with just my
hands it doesn't work anymore for me it
hasn't changed anything because there's
a certain type of excitement and
sexuality to just using my hands and
nothing else and it's the same way like
you know if I'm with Robert like it's
what's what excites me and what turns me
on is him and him touching me and not so
much what's going on you have a man I'm
by myself so I'm like I need the guys I
don't have any like hormones like
bouncing off another person I'm just
like a balance between like hands and
then vibrators because I'm just right
full-on vibrators because then it's like
a strain no I don't like that and I got
so into it that now I'm friends with
that stranger no oh wow TIFF what's
going on
one is on the outside and ones like yeah
I don't like that it's not comfortable
shoulder like one's kind of pushing up
against your knuckle deep on the [ __ ]
wait how do you there's no pretty
interesting and actually I really like
no cuz like I read this like BuzzFeed
article or something I don't know some
article where it's like women describing
like interesting ways that they've
discovered where they can like
masturbate and like certain things and
stuff like this one girl she says
actually does it face down on a pillow
and like she just rubs herself on a
pillow and that gets her off but this
other girl she was saying how she uses
like just like the two index fingers and
like rubs it like like this does
something like that and I also want to
put that on my body before and it just
kind of goes like doesn't come with any
2040 I don't know man has a squeaky back
so have you ever hit in sex toys from
your partner before did you
sorry yeah you just look so scary
innocent today we don't we don't we
don't want to know yeah like she doesn't
have a sex to it you know I'm sorry
Beau's going do you have a sex toy I
want to hear about it um okay so I have
a rodeo 3000 and it's like a [ __ ]
machine it sounds like a Harry Potter
broomstick Nimbus 3000 yeah no I'm just
kidding I do not have a [ __ ] machine
like it's just like my boyfriend I've
like walked by them before news like
imitating you and I'm like what the [ __ ]
ah dude I don't know he's probably
watching some show I needed to clarify
does he want to watch it you someone try
it what the [ __ ]
Oh like try it on no no no he looks like
but no I just have um I just have my I
just have like a couple vibrators I
actually I have this toy i I was going
like I was going on a lot of trips
before in conventions my guy got me one
of those remote-controlled ones but it
was a Bluetooth and controlled from a
distance
while I was in Texas and he was in
California it's so you could do that by
oh yeah yeah so it's just like a whole
new meaning to phone sex speaking of
things you can order over your phone
possibly on an app hungry during all
this alone time together
possibly order something from door -
right so thank you to our sponsor door -
and if you don't know what door - is
it's a food delivery app so you can just
order anything you want so they have
hundreds of restaurants that you can
order from and I love using it it's a
lifesaver I hate cooking so this is
during dinner time and stuff it's the
perfect thing to go to because you
really don't have to worry about
anything you just scroll through the app
you find your favorite restaurant order
your food and you're good to go they
have over three hundred and ten thousand
amazing restaurants and yeah in over
3300 cities in all 50 states and canada
so our Canadian brothers are not left
out so you can even order from your
favorite chains like Chipotle or
Cheesecake Factory so you don't have to
worry about dinner let the dinner how
did they know my favorite restaurants
exactly so right now our listeners can
get five dollars off their first order
of 15 dollars or more when you download
the door - app and enter promo code hey
girl
that's five dollars off your first order
when you download the door - app from
the App Store and enter promo code hey
girl again that's promo code hey girl
for five dollars off your first order
for me yes or if you
don't want to order food you want to
cook it instead but you're like I don't
want it to be hard maybe you try hello
fresh so hello fresh makes cooking very
simple it makes delicious meals it tells
you exactly how to make them and gives
you the fresh ingredients to your
doorstep instead of you being at the
grocery store like oh do I have
everything
Steve I'm talking to you every time yeah
your husband rely on hellofresh exactly
Calif fresh gives you the exact
ingredients they're organic they're nice
they're very fresh just like the title
says and they have different meal plans
which is really cool because if you have
different diets like if your pescetarian
or if your you just like meat or if
you're a vegetarian you have a there's a
meal plan for you and you can make
really delicious dinners from them it's
also flexible you can add extra meals to
your weekly order you could change your
delivery days your food press
preferences skip a week if you want
maybe you're not hungry that week I
don't know your life anyway I tried it
it came out just like the picture which
is all I could ever ask for
I couldn't even believe that I did that
with my hands but I did and and if you
want to get 9 free meals with hellofresh
go to hello fresh com /bt c99 yeah nine
meals you hungry [ __ ] use b tch nine
again nine free meals with hellofresh by
going to hello fresh com / b TCH nine
and using code b TCH nine amazing dude
I'm trying to think and I'm like I told
you guys before I had I think I I had
never had a a climax until I was 22
years old she's oh it was like 20 yeah I
think about 22 just because you didn't
know you could or you because I kept
trying it cuz when you guys were like oh
fingers are fine like occasionally like
I'd be like alright let's try this out
and I'd be like I don't feel anything
and so I would just like kind of quit it
and so then one day I was really bored
and I was determined and I was like I'm
gonna try this again and it worked
but yeah so since then would you
he's a vibrator and I didn't stop that's
a key part of it I kept going I was like
oh okay
you know I yeah and you know what since
then I've actually tried sex toys to
have like a deep orgasm because I heard
that they were so amazing and so
wonderful and like I eyed a few
different like g-spot orgasm things it
would be like it would you guys know the
submarines when that thing comes out of
the water it looked like that and I was
like great periscope is out yeah I'm
trying to imagine the toy yeah I can't
stand those I know what you mean they
like curvin yeah it's like you know now
is different yeah it hurts it hurts
because it like points up it [ __ ]
hurts trying to get it in the first I
was so stupid I couldn't even like make
myself finish and so then when I like
went to level three and trying to use
his g-spot thing can't be mad at them
for not finding if it takes us 22 years
to find it is so true me 22 years I'll
tell you that I'm with you I or gonna
orgasm for the first time when I was
watching Cruel Intentions when I was
like 13 years old I like him now more
than I did Brian I was doing a special
on motion yeah yeah I want to feel like
the petite and like dainty one in the
relationship I don't need him looking
like Skeletor what Rob's got likes I'm
trying to punch him up
we're in a fight right now texting like
him saying I need to find a trainer and
start working out five days a week and
I'm like you need to eat more butter
you're telling him to like you lied to
him about an extra person coming over
for dinner and you're like oh I'm not
coming you see what I do what I do is I
offer to make all his meals so anytime
he's sitting down I'm like hey you want
me to make you a snack and when I make
it instead of making his normal oatmeal
with the milky uses I'll use heavy
whipping cream in the wrong cream
everything I make him is just like I
just need to Pudge that [ __ ] up
so he never leaves me yeah my friends
been accusing me of fattening him we're
doing it we're 100% doing it well no
he's eating his own food but I'm letting
him because then he's gonna stay exactly
ya know good-looking man
no no tubby man leaves only good-looking
men leave like I need like I already
love you and I know what you look like
so that's enough
exactly they do the reverse - I will say
though maybe it's not even fair because
if I started dating a guy and he'd
fatten me up to keep me I'd be so pick
that's what a hood to me so now I'm
doing it to him to double in sure you
ain't yeah you saw the picture yo like
you litter it's me straight on and you
can tell this is like 30 pounds deep and
- Robert moving in with me for the first
time but it just looks like this is
normal me and it literally just looks
like just wider it all got very evenly
distributed between the face yes the
stomach and the thighs so it was just a
full-on like well when I first started
dating Steve he was going through a
breakup so he had like lost 30 pounds or
whatever it was so bony yeah when I look
back I'm like holy [ __ ] he was a
skeleton his pelvic bones with like
digging to me we're no I was not yeah
to fatten that guy yeah you know and
actually I there was one time we're like
I didn't like really I didn't see what
I'm really kinda like hooked up or I
hooked up with a guy that was like kind
of chubby and like I kind of liked it
yeah it's nice I actually liked it it
was like I liked that extra weight yeah
I feel like protected I was like you
can't get away even if I try anyway have
you ever hidden them from your partner
do we ever embarrass you no no I just
hide them from my cleaning lady grits Oh
oh my god yeah which which she has found
before and then organize it no she
organized it she organized my entire
drawer so I know she like took it moved
it along with everything else and line
them up from like sighs order no perfect
waiting all of my cords were rolled up
she was right in front of it oh my god
it was mortifying her heart video
recently I went viral where this her
friends played a prank on this girl and
they place a huge vibrator right in
front of like her luggage and then it's
like TSA check oh yeah and the guy opens
but then he goes do you guys did you
remember that story I think only Julia
was there with me but when we were
traveling for a group trip
oh she's our other friend okay yeah so I
might another friend
have I been calling one of you the wrong
name no it was a trip with all the guys
wrong because I was going with Joe and
like because we were just still trying
to have sex at that time I brought so I
bring a toy I like to use a toy almost
every time that I have sex when I'm in a
relationship I won't put a new guy
through that but in a relationship
betrayed he's a toy so anyways I was
bringing my toy with us I think to
Hawaii but then my bag comes down the
[ __ ] the baggage claim when you when
we arrived at LAX and it was just like
all these people and it's like there's
another pro tip here is if you're gonna
take your vibrator in your luggage take
the batteries out don't have batteries
yeah you know they are they just charge
yeah the new ones don't have it's like a
toothbrush one charge lasts like eight
days yeah ever tried one of those I
remember a few years ago those Hitachi's
I hate those those are back one soldiers
yeah yeah literally it is a vibrator
that literally plugs into the [ __ ]
wall for a while and I was like wow that
looks really intense and then like I'd
seen like I'd seen I I saw one in a sex
shop and so I push the button and Miley
coil on that [ __ ] lowest settings kind
of girls like I really am I'm like Louis
setting is perfect like if you a little
crazy or if the battery's dying I'll
kick it up to level two the most popular
amongst cam girls yeah but I don't know
why yeah I don't get it because for me
if they're not even attractive to look
at and they're really not it's like a
[ __ ] gun yeah but like I don't get it
because for me if it's too high in
volume and this is like I think guys
seem to understand cuz I don't I don't
know how it is for you guys but like if
you kick it up so like let's say there's
ten levels on a vibrator cuz really
often there are I'm good at level one or
level two and some guys think it's sexy
to like go up to level eight and I'm
like I can't
like I'm just dropping eggs the same
thing about men in sex period like would
you jackhammer like if you're saying it
feels good keep doing do here's look my
rule for it men if you feel like you're
exercising during sex
slow it down perfect any sweat dripping
on us yeah good pace like you shouldn't
I mean maybe a little sweat is okay but
if you feel like you're in the middle of
a [ __ ] workout like slow down also we
don't need to be picked up during sex
stop doing me too I always want to be in
missionary Oh same I do missionary do
whatever you want with my legs but just
me on my back oh yeah yeah yeah same
same and like my I guess my boyfriend
loves missionary it just makes my life
so much easier and I'm just like wow so
good look I feel like be nice and start
on top but eventually he'll like see the
just exhaustion in my eyes oh yeah yeah
and like just push me backwards
well sometimes I'll just do it just to
like you know do it a little bit and
then I clock out and I'm like I've
earned my keep by going down on him as
foreplay though like that's what I
contribute to the relationship oh there
was a somebody spoke about this any more
I think I think it was Ali Wong but it
you know it's very true I'm going on
about two years now when I don't have to
suck dick anymore no 100% you still like
really enjoy it but you know what I
don't have to do that anymore Sam and
yeah because he yeah exactly I enjoyed a
sport played against me
it gets you lubricated from my saliva
like it is just the perfect foreplay and
I also feel like if I want him to go
down on me then I should reciprocate it
but I don't even want that most of the
time oh but I like to do it while I'm
going down on him and use my hands and
then I'm ready for sentencing that's a
lot of work you're like working this and
hand in this I leave my shoulder on his
thigh and then he holds me up with it
I do like well that'll get too detailed
have you guys ever used sex toys during
sex cause that was my go-to that's yeah
another sex toy that I was gonna bring
out that I have it there's one that's
actually called like.we vibe which is
like you insert it and it's shaped like
a u so like you insert it and then like
there's still enough room for like him
to go in so then like will you excuse me
hand me my phone
oh so I need to see what this looks like
I'm so sorry like a you yeah thank you
so it covers the [ __ ] and then it also
goes inside so like the bottom part
where are you insert into your vagina
it's flat so there's still like room for
me would go in there and so like he
feels the vibration and then you're
feeling the vibration that just looks
like this this looks to me just looks
like a trip to the gynecologist like I
don't want kind of clamps opening up
that much I don't know use your vagina
hole you go like this that's still
realest that's a lot of real estate in
there you know what I mean yeah no I
mean he can put it in there I'll try it
I'll put that on my body doesn't hurt
his dick to be like rubbing against a
plastic thing oh no but then like so we
don't use that I mean we use it a few
times but we're not big fans of it but
instead of that I we ended up using like
a [ __ ] ring yeah I was gonna so we had a
[ __ ] ring but then the little vibrator
tiny little bullet that's inside the
[ __ ] ring I like to take that out and
I'll just hold it while we're having sex
oh okay does he still feel the vibration
if you take it out I don't think
he doesn't really care for the vibration
she doesn't care yeah so we're like
alright and then plus like like you guys
said like I'm definitely one of those
type of women that I can only orgasm
with clitoral stimulation so if we're
having sex and plus I'm not huge on I
have to orgasm yeah every time so I
don't we don't even use it all that
often is just whatever we're feeling
adventurous or where I'm like okay I
want to come to this time then I'll bust
it out but usually or sometimes I'll
just use my fingers or whatever
yeah the end game for sex for me isn't
always to come yeah it's like maybe once
every five times where I'm like gung-ho
about it
yeah oh me a lot less but for me it
really is important to me that he does
finish yeah that's all yeah exactly say
I get all that is knowing more I want
success
yeah you're so selfless yeah but that's
just what is that's beyond yeah do you
guys have sex with socks on it's called
feet don't bus okay guys I have talked
about this before but I legit love
bombas thank you responsible bus so if
you don't know what it is they're socks
and the kind that I have are like the
no-show socks and the reason why I
absolutely love these socks and I've had
them for years is because you know how
when you wear no-show socks the back of
it always slips out and like yeah like
especially when you're wearing certain
like tighter shoes the socks always slip
off not these socks because they
actually come like really reinforced so
that's the reason why I absolutely love
them not only that but they are made
with the softest cotton in the world
they are so comfortable and they are
built with extra cushioning and they
also have like in like arch support like
they really stitch it like tighter so I
have a really high arch so it helps me
so nice yeah why nice like a sign of
like poise and wealth if you have a high
arch really yeah
look like I walked here from Lebanon you
need to bump us yeah you girl so for
every pair that you buy bombas donates a
pair to someone in need why do laugh cuz
the way but yes so did you know that
socks are the number one most requested
item in homeless shelters well that's
why bombas they're trying to change that
so like I said for every pair that you
buy bumpass and does donate a pair to
someone in need so go to bombas comm
slash b tch to get 20% off any purchase
during their big holiday sale so
November 18th through December 5th
that's bombas comm slash b tch for 20%
off that's bomb that's B OMB a Escom
slash b tch yes and if you are wondering
who is the next person ship with I'm
wondering that all the time and I
actually have this amazing app that I'm
about to start finding men on which app
Jess there's so many this one is a very
special one it's called hinge yeah it's
our favorite dating app different than
the other ones oh you know the profiles
are set up a little bit more intricately
they would they want you to spend a
little bit more time into this and not
just like put up a picture say one
phrase and then swipe left yeah I don't
think it's a hook-up app this is more of
a serious dating app they their tagline
is that they designed this app they
created it to be deleted designed so
delete is designed to be deleted yeah
they want you to find someone they want
you to delete the app and we actually
know a few people that I've met someone
on there and they deleted the app yeah
wait did you meet someone on him yeah
yeah you've been dating for two years
one of my old co-workers he actually met
his wife on another dating app so I just
signed up for all of them and I met my
guy on hinge I tried like I tried a
couple of different ones but and I
even realized I was like yeah I deleted
it because we've been together for two
years now he gonna put a ring on it he
gone yeah I feel like I felt like with
other apps it's just like you're swiping
swiping swiping and then you you're
talking to ten different guys and
nobody's really serious but for some
reason when people branch out and they
get on like hinge like they're they're
serious and I think it I have to like
really put out there that it is really
for people that are looking for a
relationship right now
yeah they ask you really in-depth
questions right like questions that you
must answer that really get to know a
person yeah and on the app you actually
have to interact with something that
they've they've put on their profile
before you start talking so like it's
not just oh who has the hottest picture
with their tits out you know it's like
you have to go in and like react to
something that they've they've set it on
there and it helps I start a
conversation like instead of just that's
the thing is just not just what yeah
everything I just swiping well I think
the best thing about hinge though is is
the mentality of people in that app is
like they're serious I mean sure you
might find a six-month hookup but it's
probably gonna be a really nice guy or
girl that isn't really an [ __ ] like
straight up but it it's just the
mentality of people is a lot different
and I found myself having serious
conversations and it seemed it seemed
like these people were really looking
for something genuine and I mean my guy
and I we met we talked on the app for a
little bit I think we exchanged numbers
in like two days
yeah yeah and I'm weird still together
now
ss so Jess hmm you're excited are you
excited I am I'm sorry no a great story
I believe in single for a couple months
now and I get nervous and like so I have
hinge on my phone and I've like opened
it a few times I've looked around they
make you like choose whether you want to
talk to this person or not before you
can move on so there's no maybes there's
no like whatever it's like do you like
this guy or not make an answer and then
you can move on and I'm like oh I kind
of want to click YES on all of them but
I'm just like yeah take the profile into
consideration like talk to this person
or not like this is serious dating like
they want you to actually be dating
without this so that's what I like that
I'm not super super ready but I'm
getting there I'm getting there like
playing around want to continue your
bloodline download hinge today download
the hinge app Thank You hinge thanks
Ange yeah so we're now let's talk about
but toys oh my god all right say I
haven't used any sex toys but I have
used a massager like as a sex toy and I
have the same thing like you know when
you're talking about Lois settings I
think Nikki's a tough person to set it
on massage chair and just casually open
her legs a washing machine for sure I
even like has a this is I'm not proud of
but I had a clitoral orgasm on a horse
and it was dirty okay so like it was not
supposed to happen that way we were on a
tour oh my god I didn't realize like
must be ovulating or something cause
like why you guys like you barely have
to touch it it's just like oh my god I'm
there so that happened before and I feel
that cuz last night we go we got towed
and I was so mad about it my car's got
towed it is like you got some toes
inserted yeah
our cars got towed last night and I was
so mad I was like I need to masturbate
cause it's gonna finish really fast yeah
that's the thing sometimes happens very
quickly I was very angry yeah I get what
you mean though about like when you're
ovulating you're just like insanely like
anything because and I'm not proud of
either but actually I've actually orgasm
off my bidet so I needed me though eyes
it was happening cuz I was just like
actually this is all my period I don't
know why I was so horny but whatever I
was on my period so I was like you know
using the bidet to clean it and then I
was just like whoa whoa oh my god like I
was not thinking about a horse at all
like it's just like tap tap and I was
like oh oh there it is go into Tiff's
thing worth of the day I found out
because I've been super horny I had my
first orgasm in first grade Wow so I
warned in my whole entire life it
happened um I don't remember I just like
saw sex on TV or something and I started
trying to copy it and it worked and at
first it shocked me because like what
was that like I was scared I was like
what was that like I didn't know and
then like a couple days later tried it
again I just imagine masturbating since
first grade
I did find in the bathtub before I ever
had my first next toy just the water
going in operation from the bathtub
filling up I would just slide up
underneath the bathtub and like what the
water hit me like that and yeah yeah and
I did do stuff like putting my hand
there oh yeah why does that feel good
also I think I've talked about this
before but there's a scene in Fievel
goes west where he gets wrapped up in a
like a burrito by a cat looks like gonna
eat him or whatever and that seemed to
her to be on and I think that's the one
I liked that was the beginnings of like
realizing I get turned on by not being
in control and so I would think about
that scene from Fievel goes west and I
would put my hand on my vagina and whoa
I never had an orgasm but it would felt
really good where I'm like oh it's like
starting to throb you know like that
kind of thing in there yeah yeah oh yeah
the first time I ever felt anything like
that I remember I was like in the second
grade
and I was climbing up like the jungle
gym and like I was like on the pole like
I remember being on the pole and now
thinking back I remember I must have
been embarrassing but I didn't know at
the time but I was like humping the [ __ ]
we had the about the like double beam
bars that like you could oh you picked
yourself up on straddle them and just
refused to come down until I had
finished and like looking back on it
that's what I was doing but like I guess
the teachers just thought I was not
ready to stop playing I'm still not
ready just busting nuts all over the gym
oh my god I'm telling you like extra
mental padding in my vagina I'm like
don't break the hymen remember having
any like stimulation or excitement or
anything when I was younger in fact like
I didn't really care but I've also said
before like I've always been like
slightly kind of like not asexual
because they kind of reproduce with
myself but just it's just not my jam
it's not my thing you know but covered
in the cloud of Jesus no stimulation
yeah I really went for it
but well one time I watched mr. and mrs.
Smith and I think I got horny
because they were in love and they were
in love and they were expiry time in the
movie they had dicks but I think also
because Angelina Jolie and Brad Pitt
actually met on that set and I got
married after that movie I think they
had some real genuine chemistry yeah and
for me what's always been like like
stimulating for me is like strong
emotion and like the thought of being
loved
gotta be loved that is an arousal
language yeah it's huge like if I if I
have like very intimate like emotional
sex I'm like I'm like monsters now any
story you share after that you're a
monster but did you use a butt plug
absolutely yeah no of course I have no
no but like I didn't know if you're one
of those like not in the vagina but I
just never done Catholic right I was yes
but I did do that so I thought you know
virginity yeah so that was the only time
I ever tried it it went in my
boyfriend's penis went in there one time
I was like did it out yeah and then he
not too fast though then I never did it
again yeah I felt like it was just
pooping yes like don't pull it out too
fast
Oh like you're like you're starting to
dude i I've never I don't think I would
be down for like full-on like but penis
time but I like penis done I'm done for
like a little butt plug I mean they make
them like this big so so it's just
enough that you like just the hole just
it's like honestly it sounds like it
knowing all your hole to me it's really
it doesn't do anything unless you
incorporate it with sex like even if you
use a tiny one if you do it while you're
having sex that like pressure yeah it
you can feel it it's like it's like no
not enough to make you feel like you're
you know you know men have like a
prostate like they'll come to their
prostate like like if you use a tiny
vibrator or something on your butthole
well something else is happening it like
creates an orgasm that's like a full
circle like it's just crazy so when you
were saying two hands I was like also
one like pressing it that's what I love
to know I don't go anywhere near my soul
you can try
day two I'll go inside sure oh my bidet
does and I'm like you don't have to go
inside nothing as you enter just again
yeah put a little pressure I don't know
I just I'm very against any anal la okay
well yeah that's where at one time I
thought that it would be really hot to
maybe go to dinner with a little plugin
yeah and so like right before my uber
ride I was like as soon as I started
walking I was like wha - I was like not
as like sexy as I thought when I get to
the restaurant and I'm sitting down and
like I didn't plan how to tell him and
like what am I supposed to do like it's
the salads or I'd be like so what
happened he was 20 minutes of panic
where I was like why did I ever think
that this was gonna be so uncomfortable
and anxious that I would say and so then
I was like okay I need to go to the
bathroom and take this out and I'm like
oh my god where am I gonna put it
it's like should I carry I carried my
wallet in and I was like okay so there's
just little trash Kent in there and if I
wrap it up then I can just like throw it
away but I had to stick out the whole
dinner with this but yeah and then when
we got it what got back to the house I
was like look man maybe I just don't
ever tell him that it happened and like
I just it was not what does it fail it
was not fails I just stick to not
wearing panties at dinner or something
that is the worst then the butt plug
just falls out you need something to
hold it I mean like instead of the butt
plug no that's not an option
really yeah I know that's how you get
free dessert you know I've never really
I don't really use sex toys during sex
but sometimes like if if he's really
feeling it and I'm not like I'll be like
okay just stay over there let me get the
vibrator for a minute and get it started
so you use it to like warm up the engine
like get it yeah get the in a [ __ ]
works for me it warms up my
it gets me in the mindset of even though
I feel like [ __ ] and I don't want to
have sex we're having sex because it's
getting hard in my mouth yeah you gotta
go heat up the car yeah yeah have you
never had a guide say that he enjoyed
cuz like my ex like he could feel like
if I put the vibrator against my [ __ ]
and he was inside he could feel his
entire dick like vibrating as well and
he felt like that he was almost ready
for that because we would kind of have
sex for a few minutes and then I would
just kind of whip it out that was like
our sort of routine and he would be like
okay get the thing now get the thing now
he was so excited for it too like
because it's like added it was almost
like I guess the sex toy that guys have
is the UM the fleshlight yeah I don't
know that that vibrates I never used one
or seen one yeah it's almost like that
well I tried it it did not do anything
for me you did not have a dick girl so
yeah I think a lot of guys actually like
the vibration to it just depends but you
said yeah your man didn't like it it's
just another distraction for from my
experience for the guy oh I guess
everyone's different yeah I'm guys don't
like having sex in the shower because
they're like I don't to be [ __ ] you
all this water beating down on my back
yeah that's true
it's like it it's a good place to start
like that way yeah I don't like I don't
want it to feel like a workout either
yeah a couple minutes like a minute 60
seconds or so get out seconds a minute
60 seconds or 60 seconds I'm not gonna
pauses and commas in my speech like a
fitness couple like both of them are
really into fitness just be like oh my
god I like I'm just taking a shower
together and like you're washing each
other and oh yeah getting yeah gets you
in the mood but yeah it's showers sexy
I don't like it hitting my face well
yeah or it's cold because like you're
not fully under the street yeah the
worst part for me is when I shower it is
a [ __ ] chore and a routine because
I'm either avoiding washing my hair at
all costs mmm-hmm or I'm washing my hair
it's a [ __ ] process and it's not like
I can have sex right after I get done
washing my hair because then I have to
dry it and put in this serum and put in
the [ __ ] leave-in conditioner and all
of that and if I wait too long and have
sex with like my hair just straight up
wet then it's a [ __ ] nest for the
next week this is a lot of so much thing
snapchat reminded me of a picture of me
from two years ago this morning and I'm
like how did I get so old luscious you
wanted that you're fishing for all right
well like so this question came from a
viewer that has been watching cabbage
for a while but originally they sent us
a question like well how would you feel
if you found your man had a sex toy
he was hiding from you has that ever
happened to you and what would you feel
like if that oh my god that doesn't
happen unless it's a fleshlight it's
just like was actually okay solo my
boyfriend
comes over one day and this is about six
or seven months into us dating and like
we've been exploring a lot of stuff in
the sexual Oh a [ __ ] lot dude and he
and so he's like hey I really want to
show you something and I'm like okay and
he had this bet his backpack with him
and he goes into my room and he shuts
the door did you think he was a school
shooter at any point no he is white so
no I thought he was gonna come out in
like a dress like maybe we're like I
mean just cuz the way it happened
like your panic he was he was gone for a
minute you know well he actually just
came out naked with a bunch of [ __ ]
rings and he wanted to yeah like I think
he was trying to be sexy like in a like
mysterious way but we have it where was
he holding the [ __ ] ring his fingers
like I want to try these you know like
cuz he didn't know like what size or
anything like that but it was like also
kind of hot cuz he came out like all
naked ready and I was like yeah but I
would in that moment I was like I don't
think I think he meant to be like kind
of sexy cuz I could I guys don't always
know how to like do something like super
sexy I thought it was sweet but I went
to like DEFCON 5 you know I was like
he's gonna come out in lingerie and a
conversation and I would like what else
is behind like I was going through like
everything yeah but I wouldn't do an
absolute state of panic but like there's
never yesterday I think I mean he's
definitely come over before and just
been like oh I went to the sex shop and
I picked these up and we tried those
like like horny pills oh that's good
yeah
did it work um yeah kind of so we took
them like we took them and then we went
out to dinner and then we went on this
little trip and we figured by the end of
the night we'd be like all ready to go
and we were um that was fun he did bat
and it was kinda like that's like
adventures for both of you that's like
fun like hey want to try these and yeah
you guys trying to get in male and
female ones and I mean like I wouldn't
spend money on them like 24/7 but it was
fun it was exciting and kind of liked it
was something I mean how do you guys has
your guy ever at least been curious
about sex toys I've never heard any
curiosities from Steve or any of my
boyfriend's really but I think seem
naked
we're like I didn't realize I'd never
seen his butt until an episode of JK
news where we were talking about butts
and I was like they're like how Steve's
but is it here he was like have never
seen it and then that night I had to go
home and see it because at this point we
had been together for five years and so
we started calling I would never nude or
whatever but it like it wasn't like a
conscious thing where he was like trying
not to let me see him it just like we
would have sex and like he had his
clothes on so we were just like so ready
to go that like he would just kind of
and out of his five years yeah and like
we always did like missionary or doggy
styles so like I never really saw the
other side Donald Duck's it all the time
and I love it yeah it's my favorite
pictures of Roberts but on a daily what
god it's just a cutest little thing in
the layout shirt on but no pants request
little like soft wiener just kind of
bouncing along it's so cute it's so cute
the way it like jiggles on you guys like
it's so cute
when it's soft I'm sorry guys it's cute
yeah disgusting but it's not Oh the
comments for my own personal amusement
how would you feel if you were hooking
over the guard you said oh my god it's
so cool we'll just call Robert you know
what if she's getting down with it why
do you care like you think it's do
another guy like why would the
guillotine that's why that's why I like
to emasculate the minutes off so they'll
get it hard and then show me what the
[ __ ] is of your [ __ ] self yeah yeah
Jesse's like dude you hook up with Jess
she's like sitting there holding she's
like you gonna get this thing hard or
not yeah God then it makes if I did that
to Steve he'd definitely be angry and we
do like some angry so yeah oh there you
go angry sex yeah sometimes he's like
act like you don't like it
don't make me do this transatlantic so
good at improv enjoy your [ __ ] roll
buddy must be amazing I wish you didn't
know yeah yeah we do oh no can't wait we
were committed like no one laughs at
each other like it's like whatever that
person throws out there we're like yes
and this that you said I hate yes anding
during roleplay that's so funny well
guys I hope you enjoyed that episode of
talking about sex toys leave us a
comment let us know have you tried sex
toys have you not tried sex toys do you
have a stigma about it you have some
sort of some sort of pride with not
trying it let us know also be sure to
check out our sponsors door - app you
get 9 free meals oh wait door - app you
get a promo code hey girl and you get
five dollars off your first order with
nutty quit hellofresh you get 9 free
meals by going to hello fresh com /
b-tch 9 and using code b-tch 9 you save
20% off your first purchase when you
shop at bomb buzz calm slash b tch and
find a great dick in front of great
first date by downloading hinge you're
gonna so check out Mia on all of her
socials she's an amazing human thank you
so much for coming back this [ __ ]
literally cooked us three different
steaks three different steaks and hey
man cut them up and she catered to
different diets she cooked me a fish I
didn't yeah that's right you're an
Episcopalian yeah alright guys have a
good one
hi